were you guys proud of me for when kyla
was like i have some pants you can try
on that i didn't go
are you kidding [ __ ]
are you serious no they're going to fit
you they're these types they're the
stretchy like
one-size-fits-all i like that then why
wasn't i offered them
because it's ugly you're half my size
esther and these are going to be real
pants for you
not um cut offs when esther said that
she had
short bell bottoms and we both thought
about shorts styled in bell bottoms
were the bells at the knees now i want
to make that
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to blood
bath it's a show where there's no murder
yet where we punch esther until she
bleeds and we throw in a bathtub
we may get into a fight because we
disagree about everything but we're
still best bud
is blood bad welcome oh my god she also
has like a little cotton mouth so it's
asmr
i really do whenever i think about the
three of us for some reason i love
referring to us as old
fat [ __ ] it's like my addiction
i don't know why i just love that we're
we're just old fat just take it out of
the
haters mouths before they can try well
it was interesting to see how everyone
views themselves
when we were trying to pick a name
because we wanted
[ __ ] beach and esther goes i've never i
was like i've never been i'm not a [ __ ]
i've never been caught on a [ __ ] i'm
like i
have single-handedly called you [ __ ] so
many times that i
why am i still wearing a mask you're
just you're in the life
because we even though we tested
negative you
we didn't get like gonorrhea tests so
that's true
she doesn't want esther's um crotch rot
what do you call that uh
crotch rod that's so funny the only
other person i've ever say crotch rod is
my dad
wait what it's like from the 50s i know
but is that was that just like an
umbrella term for
any and all stds i would just i think
that it's
usually i would assume it's more of a
like an underwear is kind of stinky
you mean a wednesday thursday no an itch
i will say that different parts of the
month um
have different aromas right and also if
i'm really anxious
it also my body gives off a different
it's the same you have the same glands
in your armpits
as the ones you do in like your pubic
area and when you sweat when you're
anxious it's a different smell than when
you sweat when you're working out
it says we're low self-esteem come get
us you know
here they go the three old [ __ ]
talking about their
rotting crotches right out the gate i
was thinking like an athlete's foot of
the crotch
it's like guys would get it crotchrod's
more of a man thing that's why i
i feel like that's our log line three
old horses yes it is
three old fat [ __ ] but we like younger
we look younger than we are but we'll
remind you
no that's that we're not that's why
that's why it's because we're all hot
and we are not old like that's why i
like it also i just had to address a
negative comment that
was like look at them five minutes in
there talking about their vaginas it's
like
sir yeah you talk about our vaginas let
us talk about them but also
do you have you had a girlfriend for
longer than a week
have you had a peer a girlfriend for one
full month ever
okay i'm okay i'm not i'm not i'm not
doing well today because
my car wouldn't start oh yeah what
happened so that's annie had to drive
over wait she calls me panicking she has
her makeup done which is
i'm panicking once i see her makeups and
i go what are you okay
did someone die or you're going
somewhere important are you stepping in
your casket
has someone has someone done your makeup
for your final departure
um i just been embalmed
[Laughter]
i wanted to do it like while i'm still
all right never mind
so and she goes why is this happening
you're because your car is from 1992.
it's from 2001
which is in 1992 of 2000 2020.
what's your make and model esther it's a
uh 2001
toyota camry and it sounds exactly like
this
yeah that's moving but i'm really sad
i've had this car
you know this is the car i drove myself
to ballet class in when i
was 18 and i got my license two years
late and
now it's it didn't work it didn't start
today so i'm
i'm sad did you have your little ballet
slippers on when you drove
you have a little
did you ever get your tutu stuck in the
door we only wore tutus for our recitals
not for class
18 year old ballerinas first of all
exist
no but i'm were you in a kid's ballerina
class because of your height
the first thing i did my car wouldn't
start i called annie i'm like oh my god
oh my god my car won't start and she was
very nice she's like we'll come get you
like you got part of it right it's
triple a it's not call annie
then i call my dad and of course my mom
answers and i'm like my car won't start
and she's a big smile on her face she's
like oh i guess you have to get a new
car
but i'm not i'm not gonna i'm not giving
up i'm gonna call triple a tomorrow
is this the first time that it's ever
broken down yes it's just she's acting
like the car is done forever
you ever had to jump your car your
battery's dead yeah it's there's a good
chance your battery's just dead
we could have probably fixed it at the
house when we picked you up really yeah
i think i really do like i think that
the car really um is your brand
thank you yeah dented disgusting filled
with trash
it smells bad the smell nobody wants it
the defender's hanging off it's not
funny it's really unfun people get very
serious around it i will say that when i
got into it this morning i was like this
smell has taken a turn
in what direction like unmanageable
direction
like where the taco bell was ordered
vegan style but then now it has cheese
wow it's d vegan itself
wait a second esther was this the very
first car you purchased in your life
no no
and how old were you um i didn't so i
was i never had a car in high school
i still have dreams about it she
couldn't they didn't have enough phone
books
like i still have dreams like how i wish
i had a car so bad and i didn't have a
car in college and we couldn't afford it
and then
when i quit school i was like i'm i'm
going to land need a car
i'm doing this with or without you and
my dad it was like time for him to get a
new car kind of because it was already
10 years old
um so that's such a rude thing to do
like i'm giving up on my
dreams and making you proud and also
give me a car
how old were you guys when you got your
licenses i was 16. i got it right away
18.
and then when when did you actually
start to drive drive because i know you
live
you lived in philly and in the city
right and in chicago
oh wait you weren't you're in skokie
yeah skokie
suburb so you have to drive around to
get around home of the world's best
bagels and pita in the best
mediterranean food is that
is that true yes mediterranean too yes
it's so worth it
if you were to be a food you would be a
bagel or a pita
there's nothing really there until you
add something else
what are you the cream cheese yeah i'm
the creamy crusty cheese
on everything but everything
this season going back to the embalming
esther
when you embalmed yourself earlier
before you walked
i wanted to ask you guys what your
thoughts are are on live funerals
when people have their funerals before
they pass
have you ever heard of that um i think i
saw it on empire records
a living funeral yeah that's what it's
called right a living funeral like the
in
weatherman with nicholas cage um where
he basically
hosts his dad's funeral and the dad
attends
and everyone's there so you hear every
what everyone wants there were parting
words for you
oh my god the thought of a live funeral
living funeral is very sad to me i like
it makes me cringe
i don't know i don't it makes me
uncomfortable you don't want to see your
child casket
your baby you'd rather they talk about
you
afterwards well it's so sad everyone
would be so sad
do you think that they'd be that's
really presumptuous
your mom would be like this is a little
easier for me i'll be real this is kind
of nice
yo but that's always what i wonder is
someone more complimentary about you
before you die or after you after that's
what i'm saying so it's like
wouldn't you want them to say to you
know
like they won't mean it until i'm gone
exactly so it's it's a weird it's a
fool's errand this is like a it's a
it can't really ever be i like the idea
of being the person that tells the truth
at the funeral
like you're just going to go like this
person was like very mediocre
i mean is that are you practicing my
eulogy
have you guys ever delivered a eulogy no
oh but can i tell you about my
grandfather's funeral
so my grandfather died actually like
four years ago
like to the day pretty much that we're
recording this maybe a few days
and dave came to his funeral with me
and we were sitting towards the front
row my grandmother was in front of us
and my aunt who is
as you know his daughter gave a
speech and she was kind of going on
about like how he
actually loved poetry and just kind of
saying all this stuff and um
[Music]
and as soon as or no not i'm sorry
before she right before she ended my
grandma just sits there and
we just me and dave hear her go way too
much
[Laughter]
and to this day like and they're like me
and dave were just laughing in the
second row my grandfather's funeral
and we always say it to each other now
like randomly it's like our inside joke
way too much because it's so it's so
nasty to say to someone that's like
giving a speech at their own dad's
funeral it's so mean
i do feel like if the spouse is alive
though and someone dies you are
performing for that it is about them
yes it's not as much about the person
like if my
gra i've never did i he's like i'm not
human
grandparents funerals well you were born
out of an egg right
a shark egg i was incubated
i was at the bottom of the sea that's
why i like crab legs so much
no but what were you going to say that
it's the funeral it should be if the
spouse
is alive you should be just doing what
they want you should be making them
happy because they're next
i actually i don't agree if it's your
own
like if if it's your maybe if you're
i don't know i don't agree i can't yeah
i guess
yeah if one of my parents and i wouldn't
be thinking about my other parents yeah
because it's her daughter it'd be your
moment at my dad
that sounds very jazz hands i'm like all
right hit it one two three
at my dad's funeral um well it wasn't a
real funeral
funeral it was like a home service if
you will um we had this woman her name
was sister cleo
so when i first when we first the
psychic almost you know she kind of had
the same she was a black woman she was
really just the most loving affectionate
woman but when we first came from the
philippines my dad had fallen into step
with like a
nigerian mennonite church i don't know
how or why but my
first few months in america we're purely
around
this church like we would go to sunday
testimonials like my sister would do
like the ric flair dead man's job like
to pretend like
the spirit had had overtaken her so when
my dad died
um these people came over to her house
maybe just like five of them and sister
cleo insisted on singing amazing grace
and you would think that you know she
was gonna just
you know have a stellar performance but
she was so off-key
my sister and i had to face the wall
because
we were crying we were crying we could
not hold our laughter in that was the
perfect time for your sister to pretend
to be possessed
just take over the show but do it on
rhythm
as you can follow her kalila i've been
wanting to ask you something
so annie and i both have old dads how
old was your dad when you were born
well it's actually sad because he was 42
i think when i was born but
it felt like he was elderly 42. so mine
was 44. and i feel like we've bonded we
have really old dads
but then kalila rolls up and how old was
your dad when you were born not only is
my dad
dead and not only did he die he was the
oldest man
living on the earth before he went
um you guys my dad was
he was in world war ii he went through
the great depression like
he was born in 1924 so when he died he
was 79
that was in 2003 but how old was he when
he when you were born
his car was only two years when i was
[Laughter]
when i was born he was already in
he was 62. so you're like old sperm
i am super old sperm that's why i think
i have a lot of
weird um that's why you're attracted to
bobby lee
probably i always use you know what
there's never been a time where i've
ever considered
dating someone younger than me yeah i
mean try it out
try it out i've accidentally like i've
definitely had sex with guys younger
than me but never have i ever
like even considered someone
or having a life with someone younger
same my
um my friend said to me i was talking
about i was like yeah i'm dating this
this younger guy but i'll probably you
know it's not gonna last because if i
wanna have kids and get married i gotta
go with an older guy and he goes
where are the old ones are you kidding
he goes
you're so dumb he's like put them to
work you got like a young one they'll do
stuff here they send emails just get
them going
i have a steering wheel they're kids i'm
like that is a great i was like it
changed my whole perspective
i have this theory that men don't this
is a generalization not always true
but men don't really respect women their
own age they can only really respect
women older than them or
younger than them thoughts prayers
i don't think that the guys that date
young women respect them
i think it's their they're going oh i'm
going to get less
i don't have to so dave doesn't respect
me
are you of course he doesn't who would
yeah you know there is a
sense of um you ain't [ __ ] vibe that i
get from bobby
really especially when he talks about
pop culture
um he just treats me like you young kids
you wouldn't know
yeah that vibe but you're right there is
an heir of
i'm better than you and i always will be
yeah i had
i dated a guy who was 12 years older
than me and every
thing i said he'd be like you'll
understand your
is bad if i'm attracted to you you're
not
doing well that's the worst i dated a
guy when i was 22 and he was 37 that guy
that narcissist we talked about
and he would always use my age against
me that
i couldn't have met a more infantile man
in my
life but every time there was an
argument it was always like
yeah you're reacting that way because of
your age i get it it's just so
condescending yeah when i was in my 20s
i dated a guy who was like oh i just he
was he'd always say
ugh like i wish i knew you when when
you're 30 because you're going to be so
much
more mature i feel like i should call
them and be like hey guys
do you want to hear what happened to me
my car broke down for the first time in
my life i cried and called my dad
wait no joke this is i can't believe him
this is so weird
i was on a date once with a guy who was
much older that was so weird right
that i met at the comedy store and scary
no it's not someone you you know that's
the scariest one i went on a date with
an older man i met at the comedy stores
the most
terrifying lineup oh i have about 15
more stories like that
and we were like trying to decide what
movie to see and just i was must have
just turned 21
like i was so still in the daughter
mindset
that i'm like i don't know what movie we
should see hold on i'm gonna call my dad
and i on the date i called my dad i was
like dad like what's good and the guy
that i was on the date with was just
like
that was weird and i like could not
understand
what he thought it was weird because
you're [ __ ] up
i know because i wouldn't call my dad at
any point
hey do you mind wait can you just take
it out for one second i have to call my
dad
21 were you still in your abercrombie um
stage is she not in it look at her pants
no because i saw a picture of you and i
think we had the exact same skirt it was
the one like that's like two layered
little rocks yeah no that was when i was
16.
i didn't wear skirts after i got to
college the skirts didn't fit i have to
be a diet person
every time you've worn a skirt
what you've worn a skirt twice in front
of me i remember every time one was for
your special and one was
a couple months before and i filmed your
set because like this is the weirdest
thing ever
when you look like a girl i'm in such
shock what is this woman
who is this wait but kalila so your dad
was
very old when you were made what was
that like
when i was a maid when you were when you
were a maid
when you were a maid that's why you had
her he needed more help cleaning around
the house
did you how did that affect you like
were you like oh my god my dad's so old
he's gonna die
i was so embarrassed for him to come
pick me up in school or do any of the
pta stuff
and i would lie and say yeah that's my
grandpa
i weirdly had a thing with my dad where
you said pt i was thinking of pedia
when my dad would hold my hand so young
i would be and we're in we're not in los
angeles but i was like
i don't want people to think i'm dating
this old man i just had that thought in
my head
i used to have a joke about that yeah
because where people when i was with my
dad
in the midwest people thought he was my
grandfather but then in late i thought
it was my boyfriend
which like that joke still work it still
stands it does it's so weird
it's a strange thing it's also even
stranger to be a product of
such a large age gap because i never
want to think of my parents in that way
where you're
like oh yeah um he was just a really
opportunistic old man that landed in the
philippines
have we talked about this no so like
this is a
massive insecurity of mine so i when i
look at older white men and
young filipinas in the philippines you
see that a lot right it's kind of like a
not a mail order bride but they actually
go over there they don't get mailed here
they do 90 day fiance they do it right
they get on tv
yeah so i always i cringe at all of
those uh anytime i see that but then
i i keep thinking that [ __ ] like from
afar i am a product
of that kind of love and thankfully my i
really do believe my mom
and dad genuinely loved each other but
still it's like
no one's gonna know that they're they're
just gonna look at it from afar and be
like ooh
like 30 old white man with you know
young filipina
but could you use it as a way to stop
your judgment towards those
relationships of other people because
who cares what other people think right
no because there really is like a
disproportionate amount of
amount of really disgusting old men that
just kind of like
view young filipinas as like their
vacation or their like last desperate
ditch at like being with a woman and
they're preying on the fact that these
women
are so like financially like um like
you know they're it's a third world
country so they're like oh yeah um
her desperation to get out of there is
my
in and so yeah it's it's it's
it's complex and i think that there is
something to be had for both of them
they're both being opportunistic i just
don't know
if if i like it well were you close with
your dad
um it was hard to get close to someone
born in 1924
wow his walker was in the way with a
tennis ball
no he was such a cool guy he was a
linguist he was so well traveled he was
brilliant he had an iq that um
no one in my family could ever match um
i he was just a brilliant man but
because of that he was just a little
colder
not quite i'm sure he meant to be warm
but
you just it's just too big of a
generation his skin was thinning so he
was just very chilly
he was like i'm cold please i think
you're thinking of me
are you closer elderly are you closer to
your
moms or dads i'm close to my closer to
my dad but
i'm definitely i've been on a mom kick
very close
very close to both in very different
ways but i would say everyone calls me
like minnie mo
like because my dad's name is mori
everyone says i'm like exactly him
and like a female version so i like to
think i have a little bit of my mom's
looks
but then with my dad's scams
are you you must be very close with your
mom though i i don't have a choice
i only have one you know living parent
at this point
i feel similar though like my parents
are 15 years apart my dad's 15 years
older than my mom and i
there's something like creepy about that
and
my dad always talks about like and i
appreciate his honesty about it he's
like you know when you're a young guy
you always think you can do better so he
never wanted to get married and settle
down and so it's weird to like think of
how old were they though when they got
together how old was your dad
uh he was probably like 43 when they got
together and then my mom wanted to get
married and he didn't want to so they
broke up
and then oh my god and what did she do
no she didn't do an ultimatum
well no she did and then it didn't work
she said like i want to get married
let's break they broke up
and then his they didn't speak for like
six months and his mom passed away and
my mom is like such a sweet
just very sweet to everyone esther
though yes correct
and so she called him and she was like
um
i'm really sorry you know my condolences
and my dad was just like what are you
doing
and she's like what do you mean he's
like come over and then this
famous story i can't believe i'm telling
us this is that is this sex
then that night he he was like i
i want to like be with you and get
married and she was like i don't believe
you and he's like i'll prove it to you
and
you know what happened
[Laughter]
no baby esther was made oh that night
yes you're a funeral baby i don't know
if it was like it was probably shiva
hey guys say hi to lenny that's my raven
what oh god she's a witch
we know it yeah too good to be those are
my two ravens they live right above us
i feed them i throw raw meat on top raw
meat
you don't even feed them vegan that's so
rude well they don't want vegan
that's not a choice i make for them
listen esther has some newly de-veganed
food in her car back at her house we'll
have to go pick some up
please take it off my hand esther wow
there was a big proclamation of love
and then it was insemination right after
yeah it was like a proof that they'll be
together
so yeah and you have been so annoying
that
they have had to stay together neither
of them can handle you on their own that
you've
bound them so they got married at a
courthouse while my mom was a few months
pregnant with me
by a blind judge a blind judge yeah oh
i like that i wonder if it's if it
counts if they couldn't see it
a witness did they wait for him like he
had a waiting list that's why it was a
couple months
the bloodbath babes are here to talk to
you about
blue chew blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost
if you have trouble swallowing blue
chews tablets combat
all forms of ed and can help men gain
extra confidence for when it's time to
perform
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discrete package
the process is simple guys sign up
at bluechew.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part it's all done
online and then success
i wish that this was a service available
for like everything because this is so
perfect
like you get to chew it you do it online
yeah they should get it just to erect
your body to do exercise
blue chews tablets are made in the usa
and they prepare and ship direct so it's
cheaper than a pharmacy oh i love
i love a cheap cheap option blue chew
still dana phil
and tadala failed tablets are chewable
don't like swallowing pills
no problem here and don't snort them
guys okay chill blue chews licensed
medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength for your
prescription
so you guys if you could benefit from
extra confidence in the bedroom when
it's time to perform visit bluechew.com
for more details and important safety
information and we've got a special deal
for our listeners
try blue chew free when you use our
promo code bathgirls
at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code bathgirls to receive your
first month
free and we thank bluechu for sponsoring
this podcast can i just say though
it's literally free and you just pay
shipping so if this is something that
you even considered in life
now is the time to get it to support our
show try something for free and just pay
shipping
bluechew.com promo code bathgirls and to
support your own penis yeah and guys
we're not in college anymore we don't
need any ramen noodles okay
we noodles are stay in the dorm all
right
we want hard things wait okay speaking
of parents
annie this is something i've been i've
been dying to ask you
okay there's something that i've heard
of it's called landmark and i've only
heard of it because
cafe gratitude this like very cold
restaurant makes all their
workers sign up for it and it's supposed
to be this like scam
thing but you've told me that you've not
only done it
you your parents do it can you explain
what it is and if it was
18 years my parents have been doing
landmark 18 years they're still fully
committed
mm-hmm what is that what it what's going
on i'm terrified of landmark
okay one of you needs to tell me what it
is okay it's a
it's a seminar series so you go
for a weekend you go for i think it's
friday saturday sunday and then you come
back
monday or tuesday it's four days i think
and it cost
back in the day it costs i think it
costs like 800 dollars i mean i'm not
about to sign up
no no these are all important these are
should we just individually different
times we can't all bunk there together
but we have to go at different times
it's not kala tell me what it is because
this is what i know at least
about the hoffman institute which is
sort of like it jumped off from landmark
it came from est which was in the 70s
which has
gotten a lot of trouble because they
weren't letting people pee or go to the
bathroom and stuff
it's the idea that you basically break
down
somebody psychologically so that you
rebuild them so it's basic it
the end goal is to eliminate trauma 10
years worth of trauma in like a couple
days right
or in like a week i recommend
ayahuasca's way more fun
and so like i hear that you do a
role-playing game like you're a pig
like you do farm animal stuff but what i
found most sketch
is that when i look at the sites they
never list
the qualifications of any of the people
working there in fact they don't even
list the names
and it is so much money so it's like i
think they prey on people's
like rich people's like desperation yeah
it's so there's no farm animal things
unless that's a new thing that they
started doing but
they have a landmark forum leader and
you're all in this room there's nothing
on the walls there's all uniform chairs
that aren't very comfortable
they give you like a big pen and a form
you know so everything's very
there's nothing else yeah and they
just do a a bunch of stuff and and you
fight it and people fight it and then
they call it you have a breakthrough
it's like your popcorn moment or
something it's called something i i did
it when i was 19 so it was forever
so it's is it like a culti scam thing i
think it
like where it becomes if it was just one
weekend and they didn't pressure you to
keep coming back
and to bring more people i would say yes
i would say that it's or no that it's
it's just like a weekend
a weekend of like intense therapy like
stuff with people that are not qualified
but they aren't but your parents are
still doing it
right because what they do is then you
have this feeling of euphoria where they
pretty much at the end they tell you
that your life is empty and meaningless
and and then that you have nothing so
then you choose everything so
it was to the point where i okay so at
the end you're supposed to whenever you
have a
any relationship that you feel is
not where you want it to be or you've
had any falling outs with people you're
supposed to find your fault in that
and they give you a formula like i was
doing this
and i would get this from it
but the cost was this and now i want to
create the possibility of this
so you're now going into these
conversations with people who
may not really deserve to talk to you or
may not be someone that you
even need to speak to ever and again and
you're
coming to them with a formula it is good
to accept your responsibility and things
but i was to the point where i was going
to call my teacher who assaulted me
oh my god i apologized and and there's
no one to tell me not to do there's no
like psychologist to be like don't do
that
so i was about to this it was three
years after all that happened
so i was about to call him and apologize
to him for making a big deal out of
things
because life is just these are all their
stories yeah do you know what i mean so
that's where it was
really to me very dangerous and they do
it for kids they do landmark form for
for young people that to me is really
scary i don't think you should be
putting like formulas in kids heads
i think you want to let them develop do
you feel like your parents are in some
kind of a cult right now
i used to be really upset about it and i
the reason i left landmark
was because well i started to feel like
their words were in my head i didn't
like having other like why would someone
else's words be in my head
you know and they go there's no right
and wrong but if there's no right and
wrong why did you tell me what i'm
supposed to say to people
and what is the point of like
even even that invalidates all of your
feeling of feeling
wrong about something i think you can
write about situations but i think it
can help people
if they're at a specific place you know
like it certainly doesn't go
that's what that's what probably dark
for everyone like there is no
to me there's not like a clear science
behind
it and like that always worries me it
just sounds to me
very um um i guess evangelical
yeah like where there is a degree of
brainwashing involved
and there is a degree of like really
really
um breaking someone down to the point
where it's like
that then they become the only like
salvation
yeah is landmark and um i find that to
be really predatory
and i think but the thing that where it
gets bad is where they go and you need
to like and come back
and if you don't have money they go why
are you letting money stop you
you know get them like that's you know
so that's
not good and then um they go
all these people they've broken
relationships with bring them on tuesday
night
to the and then they give them an
introduction so it's like they're
essentially sucking all these people in
yeah so then it's like you bring people
and then they really pressure you to
bring people
have you enrolled people who have you
enrolled my mom would go to our
neighbor's house
we were the worst neighbors okay i love
my family
and we're [ __ ] crazy and we've been
through a bunch of [ __ ] but when i left
and i looked back and i go oh we
were the problem like by far we were the
trash people
like we we lived in a really nice suburb
of philadelphia and
and we were hell we were trapped i mean
we were loud we slammed the door
we screamed we we were my parents let us
throw parties they said like teenagers
party you know it was just
it was wild and then my neighbors
wouldn't like us because of that
and then my mom would go over and we
would make it like they're wrong
you know as a family be like they're so
stuck up they're not fun or whatever but
really they're just raising
young kids around like they don't want
their kids looking at these like
drunk teenagers and stuff like that so
my like we didn't walk our dog we just
let our dog out what people would bring
the dog back we'd be like we let her out
we don't walk her
she's just be running in the streets and
they were like your dog's eating our
garden
who cares get over it which is funny
because it has made me completely
unhinged and
i think makes me funny but it is and i
that's how i look at everything now i go
i just try to look at where it's i'm
very happy with my
current position but anyway so my mom
would go to our neighbor's house
and go i really think you should come to
land
so it's like she's telling this person
she has something wrong with them
with her yeah and she would go again and
again it's like mom you
psycho like stop doing it and then so i
i did it
with my parents and they finally talked
me into it
and i did it with them and i felt that
thing and then i was like i'm going to
call my teacher and
you know like all these kind of it was
an unsafe
area for me and then i went back to new
mexico to school
and i started doing it in new mexico i
just see them as like
herbalife or doterra there's a lot of
multi-level multi-level markers a lot of
people do herbalife at landmark
and doterra right it's like that same
that same
exact formula and they probably took
that formula
from landmark because it was landmark
took it from other people i mean it's
all a lot of politicism
and gestaltian theories and yeah but so
my parents i had ended up having a
falling out with my parents because i
i said to my mom i was like well you
need to choose between me and landmark
at this point
and my mom and i was like
damn dude so then i didn't talk to her
for a couple months and that was really
i would say that was like the worst time
of my life not talking to myself
that's like um in scientology when they
call you an sb like a suppressive person
you were technically yeah the suppressed
person years my parents would and what
really upset me after i left and then we
decided to come back
and i just you know actually one of the
things in landmark they say is you just
they go like chocolate vanilla chews
like you have to just choose like
chocolate like you just choose either
you have this or you don't
i know what the [ __ ] twist there's no
strawberry are you kidding me
but um so kind of just like you either
like have your parents the way they are
or you don't have your parents
wow and i did you know like i do feel
that way a lot with my parents were and
i've
i've i know a lot about my parents and
i've grown a lot so i do
i have a lot of compassion for them and
the choices that they've made and
i just choose to like love them no
matter what yeah just continue my
relationship with them because i
i'm obsessed with them and i love them i
respect that and it was so bad when i
wasn't talking about i would wake up
crying
every morning it was so bad people
making me like sad even thinking about
it was so bad
i really understand that a lot of times
people will say to me like you're so
lucky you're so close with your parents
and i always think like
you know that's like something that i've
really made happen yeah
that is i've made that happen totally
like i work for it
i accept things they accept like it's
not just like oh
perfect family yeah well we saw your
special nobody thinks that
we're like oh my god but do it does any
part of you at least feel because i
remember you said that in quarantine
like your parents are doing great
because they're
i came to this is the conclusion i came
to after all of this
because my brothers were getting upset
too we're like why are they spending all
their money
on this [ __ ] these programs like my
parents work for them well my dad
doesn't but my mom volunteers and works
and then is still paying
so she's paying to work for them it's
they've convinced her but
i look at it they're they're trying to
become better people at all times my dad
is spending two thousand dollars on an
add seminar that he's all excited about
he's 79 years old
he's like i'm the oldest person by far
in this but he's still trying to like
get a hold of his lady like i do love
that they're still always trying to be
better and
and work on themselves and that's the
conclusion i came to and it's just
there's no reason to fight it because
they won't choose you
[Laughter]
you just accept it so it really was
um it took a while but my brothers they
don't get mad about it anymore
it's just max never did it my older
brother did it
and we all are just kind of like all
right how are you still doing this but
they're happy they're busy during
quarantine that's what i wanted to ask i
mean like i've i've seen videos of
you guys you and your dad and your mom
and they just look like
really chipper silly people and so i i
think that ultimately
it's like you kind of allow people their
own path to happiness if it doesn't work
for you hopefully you can just like
accept it in a radical way and just yeah
you can only scream at them that they
dropped you have to get raped so many
times before you realize
they're chipper they're never going to
accept this they're just going to
continue being chipper
they meant what they did when i talked
to my mom
about like do you regret beating me
and the answer that i've yearned for
years
is like for her to get on her knees and
beg
for my forgiveness but she was just like
thems were the time yeah they can't
they can't my mother my mother
when i was like why did you let me um
allow me to sleep over at my teacher's
house and my mom goes
wait okay so okay sorry let me yeah
there was a whole thing i was being
groomed and my parents were like this is
so cool free grooming
oh my god your hair's getting cut no mom
it's different
they're giving me drugs but but when i
when i was trying when i was
really dealing with all my drama or my
trauma i was saying to them
i was like mom just why like if you
think back knowing what you know now
would you let me
would you take me there and she's like
that's just how it was back then kids
were sleeping over at their teachers
houses and i'm like
what i'm like mom you went to boarding
school you [ __ ] you went to boarding
school
the teachers lived on campus it's not
the same
but by the way years later she found out
she goes oh the weirdest thing i just
found out
she went to a a um all girls
school in new york sleepover school what
do you call boarding school in new york
and she never she was like yeah there
was this cool teacher that all the cool
girls got to go hang out at his house
and i was always so jealous okay and she
was i just never was invited and i felt
like such a loser shoes i just found out
they were all being molested by him
so she had felt left out so she lived
through you she was thought she was
doing me the salad of letting me be one
of these cool girls which it did make me
cool i'll give you that
i'm pretty [ __ ] cool
[Laughter]
i ain't basic that's so funny you know i
got teacher jazzed out of basic
i never slept over a teacher's house
well
my step-dad is actually my history
teacher so that would be weird but do
you guys find it weird that
my mom and step-dad dated after my
father passed away
and my stepdad roger he was my high
school history teacher
but i had sex with my step-brother what
is that weird i thought you were just
gonna say was it weird that
that your stepdad knew your dad not that
you
oh my god this is pornographic now isn't
it i've always felt kind of cringe about
it but i thought
looking back i'm like no like we were
friends first it's like my mom this is
like a bad
this is like the bad twist in the movie
wait you guys this is just our parents
are getting married
it's just clueless when i watch clueless
and paul rudd
it makes me feel better yeah um so i
don't
it's okay but looking back now because
this is when they weren't that serious
they were dating but they weren't living
oh
they already were dating they were
already dating that's going to happen
they were invested there's still any
vibes between you and your stepbrother
he's he he killed himself oh copy that
so so yeah that's how bad it was i think
that one of the reasons that i kind of
just wanted to separate myself
and or not be friends with him when they
did start living together was because i
felt really gross about it for a long
time
i think that that's normal where i'm
like now you're actually supposed to be
my brother but
like you know we [ __ ] like a lot of
times
was it when it wasn't when they were
living together you said they weren't
living together yet
but they were definitely dating guys was
it like they would go to one house and
you would go to the other house
um no i would i mean they would be there
like having dinner and i'd be like oh me
and you know we're just gonna hang out
i like it i think it's rebellious i
think it's like you know what
also may i add that um in high school i
wanted nothing to do with any boy that
wasn't a virgin
like i felt really safe because i had
this weird thing about sdds
so it was like oh if i only have sex
with
um virgins not only will i be remembered
in their brains forever but i will
absolutely avoid stds completely because
i had a paranoia about it
i had the opposite wow was i std chasing
i was like have you [ __ ] a hundred
women
i'm ready it's just funny because you
always hear like the sick guys that like
only want a pure
virgin but like and we've met one i'm a
sick guy
yeah that's that's me i need it to be
clean and pure for you
and shy and weak and i just was so
hyper sexual that that i had a type and
i now i
looking back i'm like gosh like that
seems
um kind of creepy but it seems like a
fear of vulnerability and a fear of
like you would be in full control of
that they're not going to hurt you
yeah and the std wise too like they're
not going to hurt you
physically they're not going to hurt you
emotionally you'll have control
which could have a lot to do with your
parents age your parents age difference
too
you're not wanting to be like have like
a more powerful is that
still your type um virgins
shy bobby does a shy character no it
really does i told bobby that he would
have been someone i would have
absolutely had sex with why
just because he was so he called himself
super unfuckable
very just not great with girls that i
would you would have been on my radar
i liked fat boys on bmx i liked fat boys
with no cars and bmx
bikes and they would lurk in my bushes
well listen it let's be real it does
feel good to be like
do a favor like where they're like
psyched
yeah or they're like [ __ ] exactly but
then they'd always i would date the fat
guys and then they would
be so mean to me and i'm like i am
giving you
a gift and then after me their
girlfriends would always be like way
hotter than they should have gotten
because i
upped their like it's for life you give
them something for life
yeah you give them that confidence to
know that they can that the
the world is their oyster and they can
get any woman of their choosing
so you are being charitable in that way
i think that's god's work
you're boosting their confidence to say
you can have anybody but then
it boosts too high i mean it always
backfired i'm like
okay [ __ ] mean making my mom cry
piece of [ __ ]
oh you guys i wanted to tell you since
you talked about being
um [ __ ] with with a teacher
yeah um this is what i wanted to say so
i have never been
i've never had relations with a teacher
but once because your mom was dating all
right but possibly worse
is i was this was the third time that i
was locked up and put in a 150 150 hold
what 5150 hold as if you are
i dream yeah i know what it is but you
had it three times
it's on esther's vision board
because i was a really you know i was
as annie puts it i was a refugee you're
a [ __ ] refugee
i had come to the you know from the
philippines and america was really new
to
me um i had a dying father obviously
because he was
97 000 years old and
i was new to this country so i was a
really depressed teenager i just
couldn't find my bearings in america
and a lot of a lot of times i try to
kill myself and i would od but the third
time that i
i were you trying to die die or were you
trying i was trying to die die
oh god i was trying to absolutely like
be gone i just could not call
if she died we'd be so poor
let's have a funeral let's do her life
funeral her live funeral
no this is making me sad but i wanted to
tell you there's a twist of this
you should be sad more often honestly
it's shocking you're not sad all the
time
when i was at the last time i was locked
up i was locked up in this place in
torrance for three weeks
and all the girls had a crush on one of
he wasn't
a therapist he did run group therapy on
occasion
but i think he was more like right below
like a social worker so he just worked
in this facility
with oh i know where this is going and
i'm getting so mad and all the girls i'm
getting turned on
all the girls thought he was so hot and
i was just so in a spiraling down that i
didn't pay attention
but on the day that i finally got out of
there he helped me pack my things
and um before i left he slipped me his
number
oh and i was 17.
this is right before i left for college
and i
could not help myself i was so enamored
by his aeropostale shirt
and immediately i called him and we
hooked up a lot of times he had kids
he was single he was a single dad but it
was like
[Laughter]
you always hook up a lot of times a lot
of times
always i've never had a boy have sex
with me and never call
i don't think i've had it either but
i've definitely ended it
yeah yeah yeah like i call them mini
romances but i had a mini romance a very
inappropriate one with this man
and um i i never thought
it was wrong at all like there wasn't a
part of me that thought oh yeah this is
this shouldn't be allowed but you guys
he was in a psych facility he worked in
a psychiatric facility
and he slipped me his number that's in
los angeles
you know what i mean so it's like these
are the stories that
we just don't know are happening every
day
that's such an abusive power i always
feel like because i went to a bad
kid's school that we were preyed upon
because we were kids at risk so that
we weren't trustworthy yeah no they
always go like child molesters they they
don't go for like
the rich kids they go for the broken
down ones oh my god do you want to hear
something that i
i got a dm from a kid that is currently
going to my high school
and he said i thought your high school
no it did not get shut down nothing
happened my parents were donating money
to it until two years ago and i was like
are you donating money to the school
that molested me
i just can't believe that they're just
in denial it's like they're never gonna
accept it but
but i so not only did i have my
experience with my teacher
i there's just so many have unfolded and
my graduating class was 17 students it
was a
it's a very small school so like a few
people didn't get [ __ ] and i feel
really that is like
so embarrassing it was me yeah you would
have been the one that slid by
but it is like like one so another one
of our teachers just got caught he was
the disciplinarian and he was the one
that i looked back at my school and i
went
at least he like he believed in us
enough to like have rules
and give us punishments which we never
actually were punished but he was just a
little mean to us
and then it just came out that he they
found all this kiddie porn
on him and he had like from infants to
seven-year-olds so we just weren't as
type was the only reason
oh my god but it was just so bad i mean
it's only he had said eyes on me
you could have gotten your diddle but it
so then i'm like this [ __ ] school and
then people were because i talked about
my
experience on on marin's podcast now
i've never heard it
yeah you'll tell it to us next week yeah
i just get something like that i just
get a little sometimes it gets me a
little too
i get a little too in it but you know
what we have
the we have years to the rest of our
lives
so everyone had heard it so the you know
there's a group of people that know
about this but
so people always tag me when there's a
new molester so on facebook it was like
oh my god another one of the [ __ ]
teachers
and then some of the kids were like oh
my god i didn't know they and was like
oh
honey pizza
we did call you pizza face for a reason
like all of us got diddle even my friend
i have a friend who i don't want to tell
his story
i'm sure he'd be okay with it but he
wrote a book about how great the school
was
and then we became friends years later
we were enemies in high school we became
friends years later
and he heard my story i didn't even like
notice that was happening
he was i really wish i'd known that
before i wrote this book and then
he his mom told him that one of his like
mentor teachers
had been writing him love letters and
and had the reason he left our school is
because they confronted him
and he admitted that he was in love with
my friend and he fled
to another school like they never
arrested and he was all about like
hush-hush
yeah so anyway so i got this dm from
this kid the other day
and he he was like i'm a current student
at the school
and i've heard on podcast what happened
no one at the school knows any of this
there's no public record i don't know
why there's no record of this
my parents probably signed a deal that
was like sure we'll keep it a secret
as long as you traumatize our daughter a
little bit more just make sure you [ __ ]
her up for a couple more months and
we'll
but so so he was like i don't know what
to do with this information he sent me
his school id so i know he's like
i feel like everyone should know he's
like i've always felt like there was
something really shady going on it feels
racist
like all this stuff and i i just don't
even know what to say
i don't i don't feel comfortable talking
to a kid by the way anyone under 18 i'm
not speaking
dm me please master esther you don't
have
skokie didn't have diddlers not i know
nothing of that
unless they hit on her now no
i did not have that i mean yeah
i don't really have my trauma doesn't
feel so real when i talk to other
comedians
oh my god when i okay i went on a date
with this guy who's a comedian and
we were sharing our like trauma stories
we're in his hot tub
and i just got done i was like yeah and
they dropped me off to get raped and
they're still donating to the school but
it's fine you know whatever it'll be
okay like i love them
vanilla chocolate chews and he's like oh
yeah when i was little my
mom i won um class clown and i was so
embarrassed by that
and my mom um
was so proud that i was class clown that
she put like a clown in my room
he's like can you believe she did that i
was like
i was like in every hole in every hole
looking at him like oh my and he
literally lives away
more [ __ ] up unhappy that man doesn't
sleep sometimes i do worry about that in
therapy because i have a specific
i have a a therapist who handles
specifically a certain type of trauma
um and sometimes i wonder if she just
looks at me and says
you are not that important like you're
you'd absolutely
like you should see my other patients
yeah it's all relative though and i
think i think it's healthy to have that
feeling though yourself because we
should be kind of
but i heard that like there is such a
thing as like toxic positivity when you
tell other people like oh you know it
could be worse
yeah look at that person like i just
don't think that that's the thing you
have three meals
exactly or like when i last year when i
had my serious depression function
like you have several meals a day i had
a friend that was like
just get outside exercise get in the
sunlight that's the funniest
thing i'm not a plant i don't know like
but i am physically a plant and not able
to exercise you know that's right yeah
and that's another thing too like
anytime they put like
tips for anxiety or panic attacks like
they don't consider the fact that
like even from you i was talking to my
therapist yesterday i was like look
i know that we are learning all of these
coping mechanisms
and while i employ them sometimes and
they work there are times when i'm
so panicked that i'm frozen and if i
feel like
i feel like if i get out of this
position like doom will
happen you know so it's like i can't
even
get up and walk across the room much
less [ __ ]
exercise no like i hate that like i just
don't like this
um you know on instagram where they just
put bullet points and i'm like there's
so much
missing context there it's not that
simple this is what i want to talk more
about because i
ended up starting lexapro an
antidepressant for anxiety and it
i couldn't be better on it and that's
why like
the people that say like just take a
deep breath i'm like
no there's something wrong with my brain
and like i took take medicine not just
your brain
don't forget the crotch rod do we want
to take a banana break
yes let's take a banana break
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god she hates that you've made her
i know
this is her molested i
really don't do you know because it
actually was a lot like that
for being molested just hold it i don't
want to
um when i was little my grandma gave me
a doll for christmas and i was so
anti-girly stuff and hated the dolls so
much that i
made i threw a big fit and i said when
we drive home the doll has to be in the
trunk
and they put you in there instead i
think that's why my grandma
i feel like that moment was when my
grandma was like i'm done with this
[ __ ]
you can't make me she died she's like
i'm dying you can't make me laugh when
i'm eating a banana because all the mush
we picked the most phallic snack also i
really
you the way you any one normal person
that's the correct way to eat a banana i
just want to say that
first but i cannot stand how people eat
bananas how do they eat them
i cannot have saliva touching my next
bite oh okay
so what you're supposed to do is you're
supposed to cut like that like so
and then you're supposed to uh
section them out now you're touching it
no no no you're sectioning them off
there so there's no saliva on either end
this is crazy there's a way
but who did you come up with this i i
think i don't like dried saliva on food
even if it's my own
i have lipstick on all my [ __ ] so just
so the listeners know we decided we're
gonna do banana breaks so when things
get too intense
and crazy we're just going to have
something they just left me hanging
earlier
[Laughter]
you could have called the banana break
we're just gonna we're just gonna chill
maybe be quiet maybe annie will shut the
[ __ ] up for a minute
and eat a banana i actually don't like
bananas so
cause other people do because it would
be easy if she liked them
i don't know i just don't really like
them so i guess her grandmother gave her
banana and a doll
producer george is gonna have to figure
out the special treat for esther
for next time oh my god it's gonna be
the most annoying treat get all the
messiest food like a really powdered
mochi
um so we're just gonna chill in the
banana break zone how's everybody
feeling
but like i honestly i couldn't agree
with this banana break
i love it i am a potassium freak
i get heart palpitations and anxiety so
when i have a potassium refill
i'm a whole new woman wow i wish you
could know this joy esther
maybe i'll find maybe i'll research what
else has potassium
a potassium supplement but you know the
they're the worst because they're this
big
but carlos is out of town how are you
gonna get him to do that for you
i love that last week's conversation
about shitpile i
really thought about that for a long
time why i bring it up every day
i'm like you know what i realized i'm so
glad you bring that up everyone
that is in my life is in my [ __ ] pile
she's either trying to
no there's only like being obsessed with
these because she's trying to [ __ ] pile
you yeah
you're all it's but my parents are my
[ __ ] pile my fiance is my [ __ ] pile
everybody's my sh my that's me i'm in my
house i'm crawling out of that [ __ ] pile
dude i'm getting off dude i'm getting
you get
you get no access to me and you're done
you'll be begging for me again i want
all my loved ones covered in [ __ ]
boy you want to give us a ride in that
car
wait esther i'm so proud of you number
one for
i hate the way eating banana sounds on a
mic though so i'm just going to put that
out there
[Laughter]
i'm really proud of you for hanging on
to that car for a long time my first car
in america that i owned at 24 was a
camry as well
but i traded it in for an expedition
because i i was living in long beach at
that time and i thought it was more
living
i wanted to be you know more hood and i
was like camry's not gonna
gonna cut it but um eventually got him
pounded
but i don't own a car you know nothing
more than that nothing more hood than
getting your car and pounded
that's good you got to rack up the you
have to rack the tickets up
so high that it's it's not worth it
to get your car back from from the pound
when i first moved to la and i was
living in my rent-a-wreck which esther
knows i was driving around in a [ __ ]
like
dented neon do you remember the like
silver i'll never forget the smell
it had the new car but it was a fake new
car smell like you could tell someone
just been chain smoking in it
and by the way rent-a-wreck is such a
[ __ ] racket it's so expensive
it's like long-term rentals for cars but
they just give you like a shitty dented
car
but i like i remember doing the math i
mean like this costs the same as if i
rented a brand new
car it's just the only benefit was that
i could
crash it nobody would know do they still
do rent-a-rack
i don't know ever since i stopped living
in my car they couldn't but i remember i
was
living in the car like sleeping in the
car and sleep at my friend's house when
i could and then if i couldn't whatever
and then um i got so many tickets that i
it was equaled rent it equaled rent i
was like i should have just gotten a
[ __ ] apartment
i should have like lived with esther and
naomi that's like bobby
um renting a car from enterprise for
like a year and a half
and he racked up like 29 000.
i can't it's my favorite story like i
know
here's here's where bobby is actually
not at fault
i knew these things about him before i
dated him before i made it official and
yet i
jumped in [ __ ] you know heart first
and now i'm complaining you know what i
mean it's not fair to him i i knew
what what kind of human being he was i
should have just you know
i always look at it like we're just um
tumbling through some of us just tumble
through life like sometimes i just come
to and i'm like what the [ __ ] have i
been doing like i just
i'm not even paying attention you know
what i will say annie the reason that
you and i have just
been such kindred spirits like i feel so
deeply connected to you so fast
is the same reason that i am so in love
with bobby
i just are you getting horny
i just love i have a type i have a type
and that is
like you guys are freaks cut from a
similar cloth
where it's like even after if you're you
are very different from each other but
there is this like
like there is you still fall under a
certain type that makes a lot of sense
to me and i feel like
is more trustworthy like i can just say
whatever i want to say without judgment
and i can just get there fast with you i
can tell you about my life and you're
not going to
be like
it's very informal like we're an
informal bunch like once you get into
banners raised by wolves yeah
just really yeah wild but also it's
comedy why are we gonna why would we do
this what's the uh
time situation why did you want to know
because i'm
cold oh i'm driving you home [ __ ] you
are
you go home when i say you're in my [ __ ]
pile today [ __ ]
she's gonna like break quarantine and go
to get an uber
with heated seats yeah i'm so i'm gonna
can i take a bath
there's enough there's enough uh old
clothes in my bag
do you want me to ask giuliana to run
you a hot pie
the pool is really warm yeah
it's really warm oh cozy
[Laughter]
can i be open about what my insecurities
are right now
yeah yeah yeah i feel and this happens
to me every time i get serious
i feel like i'm not being funny i'm not
doing it no
no any i'm telling you like i
even me never hearing some of your stuff
before like i feel absolutely honored
and interested and riveted and sad and
all of the
gamut of of emotions um when i listen to
your stories and i think they're really
important
it's so important it's i don't think you
should feel we were joking throughout it
too
yeah yeah usually when i listen back i
go okay there were enough jokes
because you've you you've lived it
you've
um talked about it and you've relived it
over and over again so it doesn't feel
exciting for you to talk about obviously
who the [ __ ] is excited about talking
just like people are like
on their treadmills listening to my rape
all the time i'm like oh my god like how
many
[ __ ] they're like i could go [ __ ]
five miles listen to this [ __ ]
it's just like it's gross
and then there's i you know i i do read
the comments
and then i get the people that are like
oh my god we do this [ __ ] sad story
i'm like i don't want to tell it anymore
i wish i didn't notice no i just want to
know about landmark
i don't know but it does it always leads
into that it's my mom wrote a book about
me i mean there's like a lot of
there's a lot of stuff there's juice to
be on
that's what i wanted to ask you guys do
you think that um
someone can be truly inherently funny
without
any type of trauma or
painful existence i don't i hate being
that person that's like you're only
funny if this and that like i don't like
having hard and fast rules about that
i would say that if someone never drank
there's a trauma something traumatic
happened for that did you have an
alcoholic
parent though i've never drank you know
that yeah but you're
are you saying you're not a traumatized
weird [ __ ] up person
are you as you're as clean as dalia pre
finding out he wasn't clean no i
i my parents never drank and so it just
wasn't like a part of the culture
in my house and my grandma's an
alcoholic yeah she still is but
that i'm saying it stems from like a
there's usually like a
you can trace it back to it a thing but
also i
i think i i
don't i would just i just have had such
a crazy life that i can't imagine not
being
had trauma and i don't know that maybe
not having trauma especially in this
world where everyone's like my trauma my
trauma every podcast you've gone is fun
like
tell me the worst thing that's ever
happened to him like jesus nice to meet
you
but okay i don't know what do you think
kala
um i bobby always talks about this
theory as to why he thinks like koreans
and filipinos
are inherently more what he considers
funnier than let's say like
chinese or like oh my god i love
japanese people
yeah the inter-asian comparisons
and he says it's basically it's a
historical
um it's a historical thing where it's
like you know
if you've been colonized and if you've
been raped and pillaged as a culture
you cannot like comedy is its survival
like
that's why i find like the filipino
spirit to be so
um like it i have never seen anything
like it like
their homes could be ravaged roofs off
from like a typhoon
and the next day they're happily like
swimming in flood water and the kids are
playing and everyone is just like
it's okay it's mother nature we'll
rebuild like there's so much joy there
and for a third world country there is
more joy there than there is
in america like everyone when i first
came here the one thing i said was
there are so many rules and everybody is
sad and angry
like that was my observation as a
teenager and
i missed the joy of back home even with
so that's bobby's theory is that funny
does come it has to come from
a pain whether you're conscious about it
or you're not well i think it's a
defense mechanism
also just similar like jewish people are
tend to be funny and yes
you know we had our little thing and you
know hitler really
he had a good point i mean he was like
they're getting a little sluggish on
their
punch lines they're slowing down we're
gonna need to really
bring them up it was like it was like
going to ucb for five
five five level five i don't have the
energy to fight that right now
guys i'm so [ __ ] cold i'm so [ __ ]
cold that this part you should be
grateful you're cold your people were
very hot every time andrew
andrew letterman i need a [ __ ]
blanket
someone needs to give me a blanket i'm
gonna freeze
i gotta get out of here this is my
favorite part of the episode if
anyone's wondering this is the clip just
esther's screaming do the wap dance now
esther generate she can't help it
she can't not do the whop
crush the headphones make it worth it
okay we could we could rap it's been a
pleasure
as always um thank you annie for
for your landmark stories yeah i feel
like we gave people a lot of spank bank
today
kelila had sex with her brother yeah
that actually is
and he had sex with her teacher no i
didn't need jizz remind me to tell you
my other
um sex with my other brother story oh my
gosh there's been more
than one video i have a twin and i've
resisted all this time
he's hot he looks just like me you guys
thank you so much for listening to
bloodbath uh we're
three fat old [ __ ] and if you want
more of this like this video and
subscribe
oh listen to her sex voice this is this
is the voice of someone who didn't get
molested
she's just trying she's trying to make
up for old time
for lost time that's been our show
see you next week ew is everyone
comfortable with esther being the take
the
reigns person it's disgusting she can't
even do it seriously she's a gyrate
while she's doing it
business esther is just like in a sec no
you're like a sex worker when you do it
every time you do it you're like
[Music]
you